well first of all let's talk about this
haircut this looks
amazing when did you chop chop it's like
two days ago
we are fresh e.t exclusive the haircut
has happened it's like my laura croft
badass 2020. i'm here for it bring it on
bring it on what are you ready to be
brought on i mean everything right now
i'm here for
everything say yes to all the things is
my new motto yes
to everything because here's the thing
when a new season of housewives is
premiering
the bring it on means the commenters the
criticisms the drama it all
are you ready honestly that is such a
small part of my life and what i'm
dealing with right now
it's like oh if you actually know what's
going on that's such a small thing like
okay whatever you know what i what i
went through
what nine eight months ago now when we
started filming
i've already gone through that i've
already dealt with that i'm already on
to new dramas new disasters
what are the new disasters you know our
life is crazy
and even though i feel like we all took
a pause in 2020 for some reason my life
seems to be on fast forward
and the change the decisions i made
eight nine months ago
obviously have had a lot to do with
where i'm at now
and i don't know i'm just here for it
the year of yes i'm excited for 2020.
this is my party how dare you these
women are horrible
they lie to each other all the time so
where are you at now
um so today i am 256 days sober
one day at a time 256 one days at a time
congratulations how do you feel about
that
grateful i think i have a lot of
gratitude
i have a lot of amazing people in my
life that have supported me and i'm so
thankful that i was finally able to
realize that i can't drink anymore i
tried every way to drink
and none of them work and so having that
weight lifted off me that it's not a
choice anymore i just
like i said one day at a time because i
don't want to get ahead of myself um
you know but for today i don't want to
drink and i feel so good
i feel great in that premiere you say on
camera my name is bronwyn and i'm an
alcoholic
what was that moment like for you to say
that knowing it was being filmed and
that it would air
all over and that you could not put that
back in the box
by the time i said that in the
confessional it was okay
i had already said it to myself i think
that was the hard part the first time i
said it to myself so
when i quit drinking it was january 30th
2020.
and i had my interview for the next
season
where we sit down with the producers to
go out what's going on your life uh
february no january 31st
the next day the next day so i kind of
tiptoed around
oh i'm getting healthy whatever i hadn't
committed i just knew i had i knew
things were out of control i knew my
life would become unmanageable
and then i called captain sandy from
below deck mediterranean
and i knew she'd been sober for 30 years
and i got her advice and she said you
had no problem being drunk on camera
why are you having such a hard time
getting sober on camera
and i had to admit the truth was because
then i would be
accountable that was scary so
once i talked to her i called my
producer and i said here's the truth i'm
an alcoholic
i've struggled this for many years this
is not my first time trying to get sober
i went to rehab ten years ago this is
not new
um this is just something i didn't tell
you guys this is something i kept to
myself thinking i could keep it under
control
and he said okay do you want to film
this i said i do
and i said i want to do it right i want
to do it honestly and i don't want to
sugarcoat it he's like okay we're in
so by the time i said that in front of
all of you
i had already started going to support
meetings
i'd already started taking the steps
that i needed um
you see a crazy scene on camera where i
throw a glass and all that
that was my rock bottom that was 30 days
sober
i hadn't gone to get any help yet i
thought i could do it on my own and you
see
that day the progression i tried to kick
the cameras out of the house
i mean i really tried and they followed
me that whole day
and they are integral in me getting to
my first
self-help meeting and me getting sober
and staying sober
[Music]
goodbye thank you
when you say that you throwing that
glass because that moment's in the
trailer you throw in that glass we've
seen it that that was your rock bottom
what made that your rock bottom and did
you go have a drink that day was that a
relapse day
no that was i was 30 days sober and my
sobriety date hasn't changed
but i had not asked for help i really
wanted to do it on my own
um i was nervous to go to a self-help
meeting
uh i was nervous i'd be recognized i had
shame around it
i had a hard time walking through those
doors
that day in retrospect i shouldn't have
gone
i shouldn't have gone in the state i was
to a party where everyone was
tequila tasting where people were i
shouldn't have gone i shouldn't
and looking back i know that and i had
an altercation with a cast member
at the time and you know here i am
trying not to drink and they say go to
the bar go have another drink
go have another effing drink that's what
you always do
and that sent me over the edge when i've
been trying so hard
to stay sober and keep it together those
words
and i just said that's when i threw the
drink and said half you
did they know you were trying to be
sober at that point no the person who
said it to me gina did not
okay she did not know if she had known
there's no way she would have said that
she had no clue a couple of the other
cast members i'd told at the time
but no she did not know so what place
are you two in now have you
moved past that we have we've moved past
that she's actually was probably the
most supportive
of a lot of things you know getting
sober was
alco like drinking was the way that i
dealt with things
that wasn't the only problem so
obviously when you get sober you uncover
a lot of other things and it's a journey
and she's been very supportive currently
i'm not speaking to anyone on my cast
for different reasons um
but you know i think when you go through
a change like this it's uncomfortable
for people
it sounds like the crew and the cast
knew some of it but not all of it
yes i mean that's one thing i think
that's pretty typical with
addicts is that we're really good at
hiding things that we don't want people
to see
you do that moment with emily you're
very emotional in that conversation so
is your goal going forward to never
drink again
i don't think i can ever drink again
okay and i honestly can say that that's
like that scares the sh
out of me but yeah it has to be forever
when you do think about maybe what your
emotional
rock bottom was what moment comes to
mind shannon's party that glass throwing
that was and what led and the moments
after so i leave the party i walk home
since we're so close
i say get the f out of my house i'm
spiraling i was spiraling
fast and uh if the crew hadn't have been
here
i know without a doubt i would have had
a drink that day i know that so we've
interviewed
shannon recently and emily recently and
they both
called you out on your authenticity in
our interviews and the love shack came
up i think shannon said she thought it
was all fake
and they think that you are not being
authentic and you're sitting here
talking to me and you're saying i'm an
open book so yeah
what would you say to the two of them
about that i think it's hard for them
because
if i'm honest then what they've said
isn't real so it's easier to cast doubt
on what i'm saying than to take
responsibility for some things they
might have said
like what well you'll see this season
um i know out of everything you can call
me um and i will take it uh one of the
things about getting sober is you do
have to do a pretty
hard inventory and look at yourself so
out of everything you can say that's the
one thing that you can't right now
i am literally i haven't told one lie
this whole season
okay like not one not one
who do you think is the biggest liar on
the cast shannon
really yeah i i think her words to me
are because she likes to do a lot of
stuff off camera
is if you say anything i'll deny it to
the very end and i'm like i know honey
you've done it to me
what's a lie that comes to mind it was
the silliest one
it was the thing about her saying gina's
house was sad
and it was such a little lie but it
became such a big deal because she just
wouldn't
own it i'm like this is nothing don't
you dare accuse me of something that i
did like during the season i talk about
getting sober
talk about hitting my husband like i
mean i go there
i talk about not being able to breathe
like i when he's around i mean i
i have opened up things that even i was
like oh my god what was i doing
you know when i was in confessionals
talking about it and
for something so small to become such a
deal that was just sad to me
it's not that hard to be honest
it's really hard to lie and then cover
your tracks
so getting that into some of the
darkness in your relationship with your
husband getting into
just everything you've dealt with what's
one thing
that you've learned about your marriage
and about him and what makes it
work through all that honesty and
communication
we had to have some really hard long
talks and don't get me wrong this has
not been
easy i mean you know
his all his belongings might have ended
up in front of the house a
while ago oh how long ago you know
like all those rumors i know where they
were coming from they weren't based on
nothing
obviously whenever you hear something
it's usually there's a there's a
grain of truth to almost everything
that's out there about me um
so we've definitely had hard times so
for us sometimes we have to blow
everything up
to patch it back together where are
things with you guys right now
i mean it's been a struggle and i will
say that
when someone in your family gets sober
alcoholism is a family disease
um it's affected him it's affected the
kids especially the older ones because
they have gone down this road with me
before this is not their first time
the little ones are a little more
insulated from it but you know he has
his own self-help program that he's
working
um you know that deals with enabling and
living with an alcoholic
and you know we're definitely finding a
new normal
um our roles have changed you know he's
not
the babysitter he's not taking care of
me right now and so we're finding a new
normal
uh we're re-negotiating the terms of the
contract when it comes to our marriage
for sure
okay you know like we're what does that
mean are you do you
do you consider yourselves to be
together right now are you absolutely
okay you are we are
we will be married forever we have 100
faith that we're going to grow old and
raise our grandkids and great grandkids
together
that being said do we have to fall into
the social norms that everyone else does
no and you haven't you've been very open
on the show
no so we're doing it our own way and
that's why i said modern marriage you
know i
obviously every there was a lot of
information out there that we were
divorcing which is not true we're not
divorcing
but are we redefining what marriage is
to us yes we are
we're going to see covid play out they
have shut
the entire country down
they're stopping production you're
supposed to be six feet apart
sorry no no sit down put your head
between your knees what was it like for
you guys to film because
i feel you guys were filming things are
a little calmer now but when you were
filming it was scary and we knew even
less
and it just seems really intense it was
it was intense
i had my kids coming back home i had
eight kids because bella brought her
boyfriend from college
we went in full lockdown uh only sean
would go for groceries
so i mean we had this whole house down
we got rid of the nannies the
housekeeper
you took it very seriously you know i
come from a family of physicians
so we were following all the safety
protocols and
i mean it was it was scary well and
kelly dodd certainly got herself in a
lot of
controversial conversations over the
summer
yeah i mean not that that's new for her
and then she she
she brings a lot of of story i wondered
what you thought of
her just being in all those
conversations
i mean the fact that she didn't take
covet seriously
that i didn't understand that i mean
leaving your daughter doing a global
pandemic
was weird to me i can't imagine that um
but the main thing for me was when we
really got into it over black lives
matter
and that's sort of when i went you know
what i'm out i'm not doing this i called
my producer at that time and i said
it's like a group text i said i don't
belong here i don't belong on the show
i know i'm in a contract i have to keep
filming but like i need a person
i need like a decent human on this cast
and uh he is god bless him he talked me
off a ledge
so you felt like there was nobody who
you could turn to
there isn't anyone on this cast i can
turn to when it comes to you know
how i feel vocally how i feel about
black lives matter how i feel about
lgbtqi rights there's
no one on this count that i can turn to
what do you think of the way that they
feel
i think it's very indicative of where we
live have you been thinking about a drag
name
divine divine
i i don't know if another housewife has
ever shared the journey of talking about
their child kind of exploring their
gender and figuring that out was that a
problem with the cast
yeah yes yes
um and we did i would say at a certain
point of filming we
we railed it back when it went from
costume
to identity or jacob said hey i'd like
to take a step back and we respected
that
so um but and you see all that and
and i will say though like gina
respected that when i said hey i'm not
going to talk about that now she was
like okay i get it
um but the rest of the cast instead of
listening and supporting like when they
had a chance
to be an ally they were just really
judgmental and put it down um
it was hard it was really hard on a lot
of really basic human levels
for me like every part of my character
was attacked
and some of these things are who i am
and it was just
relentless you know relentless so that's
why you're not speaking to any of them
now
or did additional stuff happen um mainly
it's just
you know i'm so where i'm at right now i
think when you get sober you learn how
to put healthy boundaries
and you learn what to expect from people
and what you'll
what you'll put up with and how to kind
of
protect yourself and like i know my
worth i know what i
contribute to a relationship and a
friendship and i'm not going to settle
for anything else
you